Okay, good morning everyone.
Welcome to the first lecture of AI in
the science and engineering. My name is
Sid Mishra and I am co-teaching the
course with Ben, Ben Mosley. Ben is
going to teach you today, but I will
drop in on next Friday for the first
lecture that I'm going to teach. We are
going to share and Ben is going to also
show you the lesson plan. So now,
without further ado, I hand you over to
Ben.
Thank you very much, Sid.
So, welcome everyone.
This is the first lecture of this
lecture series, which is AI in the
sciences and engineering.
So, as Sid said, my name is Ben Mosley,
and we're going to be teaching this
course together
throughout the spring semester here at
ETH in 2024.
So, what I'm going to do is dive
straight in and give you a very
high-level motivation for the course.
And then, after I've given you that
motivation, I'll talk a lot more about
the course contents,
the assessment, and the practicalities
of the course.
So, let's just dive straight in.
So, AI is having a massive impact in
science today. It's driving lots and
lots of breakthroughs.
And I would say, especially in the last
year or so, these breakthroughs have
started to gain widespread attention in
the public.
And what I've got here is a few examples
of AI really having an impact in
science.
Um
And so, the first example is using AI to
forecast the weather and to do climate
simulation.
Um so, companies like Nvidia with their
forecast net model,
also Google with a model called
GraphCast, and many other companies too,
are able to now train AI models that are
able to accurately simulate the climate
and and weather patterns.
Um to an accuracy that is competitive
with and, in some cases, starting to
exceed
traditional numerical simulation.
Um and this is really exciting because
not only can they perform very well, but
they're also orders of magnitude faster
than these traditional numerical models.
Uh so, this is an example of Forecast
ForecastNet predicting the global global
weather patterns.
Um so, on the top right here is a news
article that was that explained how
ForecastNet is was able to forecast
Hurricane Lee. So, this is an extreme
weather event up to a week in advance.
And these models are actually very
different to traditional numerical
simulation
because they're very heavily
data-driven.
And so, the way they simulate is that
they learn from lots of previous
observations of the climate, real data
measurements that we have,
to be able to simulate forward in time.
And so, this is kind of a transformative
change in the way that we think about
climate simulation, and it's really,
transforming this whole field.
Here's another example. This is using AI
to help us carry out nuclear fusion.
So, what what is nuclear fusion? Well,
it's an alternative
way to produce energy.
And it does it by combining atoms
together, so fusing atoms and collecting
the energy that they release.
Um
So, to create fusion, you basically have
to recreate the conditions inside a star
here on Earth.
And to do that involves
creating a plasma. And this is a a state
of matter which is very high energy
and very high temperature.
And these plasmas are really difficult
to control and they're really unstable.
And so, this research, this is a
collaboration with DeepMind and EPFL, so
here at ETH in Switzerland,
they used a neural network
and in particular, they used it using
they trained it using reinforcement
learning to control a real-life
nuclear reactor.
And what you can see from this animation
on the on the top there is that this
this trained neural network was not only
able to
control the shape or change the shape of
the plasma, but also keep it stable over
longer periods of time.
And so, this was a really
this AI here is really giving us a step
forwards in producing energy with with
nuclear fusion.
Then, the final example I've got is
AlphaFold, and
this is
an AI model from Google DeepMind that is
able to accurately predict the 3D
structure of proteins given their amino
acids built their building blocks, which
are their amino acids.
And this is a task that
used to take a lot of
painstaking effort in the lab, months
months to years in the lab. And now, we
can
predict the structure of these proteins
in seconds just on a computer.
And this has allowed many downstream
applications, for example, in drug
discovery,
and has become its own research field in
its own right. So, AI is really
transforming this this area of science
too.
So, why is AI impacting science today in
such a big way?
Well, the reason is because AI itself
has exploded in the last decade or or
so.
And there are some really powerful AI
technologies in the world today.
Um
Most of you, I'm sure, are familiar by
now with ChatGPT. This is the the model
that's taken the world by storm over the
last year or so.
And
more generally, large language models
are able to have full conversations with
you and do things like summarizing
documents and even creating fully
autonomous like digital agents.
Um another
impressive breakthrough has been in
image generation in AI. So, we can now
take a text prompt,
for example, a photograph of an
astronaut riding a horse,
and we can generate a very highly
realistic image from from that prompt.
I mean, just last week, OpenAI announced
Sora, which is a text-to-video uh
uh tool,
and that generates incredibly realistic
video from from text.
Um on the on the top right here, we've
got
Gato. So, so there is also a trend in AI
right now to
not just use AI to carry out very narrow
tasks, but also to be more general, to
become generalist agents.
And so, Gato is a model
that is able to do not just image
classification, but it can also caption
images, it can also play Atari games,
and it can also have a conversation with
you, all using the same the same model
under under the hood.
Um
we use AI today to help us code. So,
GitHub Copilot is really good at
completing code and suggesting a whole a
whole blocks of code for you.
Um AI is the fundamental technology
between autonomous cars, and and we also
use AI to translate now very
effectively. And AI can translate
seamlessly between hundreds of different
languages.
So, if you look at these graphs, you can
also see in the numbers, the number of
research publications in AI has been
growing very quickly.
The amount of funding has been growing
more or less exponentially.
And another kind of interesting trend
recently is the number of laws that have
been passed in AI is also going up, and
we're starting to really think about the
the ethics behind behind AI, Sid.
So, why has AI itself exploded?
Well, I would argue that what has been
driving a lot of the progress in AI over
the last decade or more,
90% of that progress has been driven by
deep learning.
And and deep learning is the training of
of deep neural networks.
So, before I
go any further, I just want to explain
what deep learning is just to make sure
that we're on the same page.
So, yeah, deep learning is concerned
with training deep neural networks.
And
at the risk of
being too simple, but also, I think this
is a very useful way of talking about
deep neural networks, particularly for
this course.
Um
I'm going to describe a deep neural
network as simply a mathematical
function.
So, here, N of X,
where where the function takes in some
vector input X, and it gives some vector
output Y.
And what's really important is that
function has some free parameters, we
call them theta.
And these these parameters are tunable.
And so, we tune these so that the output
of the neural network matches some
desired output from some training data
set.
Um
and then, training basically involves
having lots of examples of inputs and
outputs of the network.
You also need a loss function to compare
the outputs of the network with the
output of the model.
And some optimization algorithm that is
able to tune the weights based on that
loss.
So, that's very simply what a neural
network is, or a deep neural network.
Um
then, the next question is, well, what
exactly is that function, neural network
of X?
Well, that function then depends on the
specific neural network architecture
that you're using.
And there are many many different
choices,
but pretty much every neural network
architecture can be described in in this
kind of simple simple way.
The final question is, what makes it
deep? Well, usually we say a deep neural
network is any neural network function
that has more than two layers, or two
two layers or more.
So, why now? Why why is why is deep
learning really exploded recently? Well,
there are broadly three big reasons why
why it's so popular.
The first is that there is exponentially
increasing amounts by by some measures
of data in the world and and you can see
that on the chart on the left.
Huge amounts of data but the these that
allow us to train deeper and deeper
models and more and more sophisticated
models.
The second reason is the amount of
computational power has also been
growing exponentially more or less.
Perhaps not in computer in CPU power
anymore but but with the advent of GPUs
which turn out to be really amazing for
training deep neural networks, we really
are seeing scaling in terms of compute.
And then finally we have a lot of more
mature deep learning frameworks that now
allow us to train neural network in you
know one, two, three lines of code.
So these are platforms like PyTorch,
Keras, TensorFlow and JAX.
As well as that there's also been a lot
of innovation in in the
training algorithms of neural networks
and also their architectures and there's
a lot of interesting work there.
Okay, so I showed you some examples of
AI really impacting science today. Um
and what I tried to do here is is to
think about some of the grand challenges
in science that you know AI could really
help us solve and there there are many.
Um
you know there are some really big
problems in science that would really
benefit the world and humanity if we
could solve them.
And so what I've got are four different
kind of grand challenges that and I'm
and I'm going to explain how I think AI
can help this.
So so the first big challenge I would
say is on the top left and and that's
the the challenge is the amount of data
that today's experiments or some of
today's experiments are producing.
So this this is a plot of the data that
is recorded every month at CERN.
And you can see the CERN is recording
thousands of terabytes of data every
month.
And this is just impossible for for a
human to go through by hand and pick out
you know the needle in the haystack, the
different particles or interactions that
we're looking for in that data.
So AI here could really help to automate
our discovery process and our processing
of that data.
So on the on the flip side there were
also experiments that we carry out which
have very little data and the data that
we have is very very noisy.
So an example of this is exoplanet
discovery. Um
And the most popular way to to discover
exoplanets today is to use the transit
method.
And this is very simply where you where
the where you see the planet directly
transit across the face of the star
and that causes a very small dip in in
the flux that you that we receive from
that star.
The issue is that that flux change is
very very small. It can be less than a
percent change.
And it and it produces measurements
which are very very noisy and
I mean to the human eye it would be very
difficult to detect a transit based on
based on that data.
And so AI can really help here to help
us pick out signals from noise. Um
So this is another another big area
where AI can help.
Okay, let's go to the top right.
This is the task of simulation
and the difficulty that we have with
many many simulation algorithms across
many different domains is that they are
often very computationally expensive.
So this is a this is a simulation of the
flow past an aircraft wing.
Obviously a really important simulation
to make sure that our aircrafts are safe
and also efficient.
But these types of multi-scale high
fidelity
simulations
can take you know millions of core hours
and also millions of dollars to to to
run.
So any way that we can speed up these
simulations using AI machine learning
could have a really massive impact in in
in our simulations.
Okay, finally on the bottom right um
a lot of the scientific experiments that
we're carrying out today or the the
scientific systems that we're studying
are becoming more and more complex as we
learn more and more about them.
So a good example is the COVID virus and
and how that virus evolves through time.
And this is actually a super complex
problem. Um
You're you're modeling the transmission
across the entire world essentially.
And we have a lot of data here and what
AI might be able to help us do is
discover patterns in that data that we
may find it difficult to do by
ourselves.
So yeah, rather than me telling you why
deep learning is important for science,
I thought I might as well just ask AI
itself.
And so I asked ChatGPT
what are the benefits of using deep
learning in science and and ChatGPT
actually gives a really brilliant
response. It basically summarizes what I
just told you.
So AI can help
improve the accuracy of our scientific
scientific algorithms.
It can also help us automate and
automate the discovery of
from our scientific data.
It can enhance our understanding by
maybe detecting patterns that we
wouldn't be able to see before.
And yeah, increases the efficiency. It
can help speed up some of our
computationally expensive workflows.
Okay, so I've got a couple well I've got
two more slides of applications of AI in
science to to convince you even further
that this is a really impactful
technology.
Um
and what I'm showing is many different
applications across many different
domains and I'm not going to go through
them in detail but I'll give you a quick
summary. So AI is helping us take images
or scans of our eyes and segment those
images and and be able to detect
issues or diseases in our eyes.
AI is able to take images of gravity
gravitational lens galaxies and
undo that lensing and reconstruct the
image of the galaxy without that without
the lensing.
Very accurately actually.
AI is also able to go through data from
particle colliders and
and detect detect events in those in in
that data.
AI can also take recordings of our
neural activity and decode the speech
that we were saying uh
just from that neural activity.
Helping us to understand the brain and
how yeah how our brain works.
Here's here's a four four more examples.
So this is the work that we did where we
used AI to look here into permanently
shadowed regions on the moon.
And so so these are craters and other
topographic depressions that are
permanently covered in darkness.
And
the images are very very dark and very
very noisy. And so we trained AI to
remove the noise in these images and and
for the first time allow us to see
craters and and boulders and other other
objects inside of these regions.
AI can help us design antibodies. So
this is an example of an AI actually
discovering a new antibody for E. coli.
So this is a bacteria.
And it does it by using a message
passing neural network which is trained
on lots of examples
to predict various molecular properties
that can cause resistance and and then
when it's tested on new molecular
designs it can come up it was able to
come up with this new antibody.
AI can can solve
Olympiad level geometry questions and
this is
AlphaGeometry and and this is really
interesting because it combines a large
language model with a symbolic inference
engine to to carry out that task.
And then AI can also help us
code our scientific workflows and and
this is an example of a ChatGPT actually
doing a really good job of
writing code to solve the 2D diffusion
equation.
Okay, so I've I've really picked up deep
learning and AI and
and the potential for its impact in in
science and now I want to bring it down
to reality a little bit and tell you
some of the challenges of deep learning
as well.
And it's really important to recognize
these challenges especially if we're
going to apply AI to to scientific
workflows.
So there are some big challenges that
are very well known by now of deep
learning in particular.
And I'm going to go through go through
four of them.
So the first kind of big challenge is
just the sheer size of the models that
we're training today.
So if you think about ChatGPT kind of
the early versions of ChatGPT
took 175
so hundreds of billions of parameters
just to train to train that model.
It also took a huge amount of data
essentially scraping
the internet to to be able to find a
training data set for that for that
model.
There's a graph here which shows the
trend where the number of parameters
versus time
of some of the major machine learning
models that have been released and and
you can see the trend is going very very
much upwards and we're we're getting
towards trillion parameter models.
And so even just storing these models in
memory on the computer and and doing
inference on the can be a challenge.
Um
AI
also suffers or deep learning deep
neural networks also suffer from bias.
And
a property of deep neural networks is is
that if you have bias in your training
data, that is also going to show up in
the outputs of the model and
unfortunately a lot of the data that we
have trained deep neural networks on has
been has contained biases in.
For example, when we're carrying out
facial recognition and the performance
varies across
different groups of people.
And so this is really important
consideration to make sure that our
the AI that we train is fair and
ethical.
A kind of related to that is the inter
lack of interpretability of deep neural
networks.
And this is fundamentally because neural
networks use the distributed
representation
when they're processing their inputs.
And this can make it really hard to
interpret what they're doing or or to
get them to justify their actions.
So for example, if you were
training a neural network to drive a
car,
you would really want it to explain why
it took a left or right-hand turn based
on its inputs and its context.
Then the final challenge
is actually the designing the neural
network itself and
it actually is not often obvious what
the right right neural network
architecture that neural network
function that I showed you
should be for a for a given task.
And I would argue that a lot of the
progress in AI or a lot of the research
in AI over the last decade has been
experimenting with lots of different
architectures.
So if you think about for example, image
recognition, you know, a classic task in
computer vision,
we've gone from fully connected networks
to convolutional networks to resnets to
transformers. We're still we're still
kind of playing around with the best
architecture to to use.
So I have two more challenges which I
think especially pertinent to using AI
in science.
And the first of those two challenges is
the challenge of generalization.
And so this is the property of deep
neural networks that
they often perform very well when you
when they're given an input that's
within their training distribution or
close to their training data.
But as soon as you give them an input
that's outside of their training
distribution, their performance often
decreases very rapidly.
So this is a test I did myself. I took a
a pre-trained resnet that was trained on
ImageNet. So this is just uh
thousands of different natural images.
And if I get it to classify an image of
a dog, so this is an image that's within
its training distribution,
it not only nails that it's a dog, but
it also tells us the specific breed very
accurately.
But then as soon as I give it an image
that's outside of its training
distribution, so some sort of space dog,
it doesn't it really starts struggling
and can't can't label it correctly.
So related to this and perhaps a a kind
of a wider wider kind of issue is the
challenge of reasoning with with deep
neural networks.
And they can often struggle to
exhibit kind of common sense reasoning
in their outputs.
So this is an example
doing image generation with DALL-E 3, so
you know, a state-of-the-art image
generation model.
And I asked it to produce a street with
absolutely no lamp posts and
rather than producing what I asked for,
it gave me a street with lots of lamp
posts and so the exact opposite. And so
and so what you can see here is that the
model is struggling with this negation
of the logic in the logic behind the the
statement.
So this is an outstanding challenge and
definitely a a very hot topic of
research at the moment is putting
putting more common sense reasoning into
neural networks.
So I showed you the challenges
talking
through the lens of traditional AI
tasks. But what is really important to
understand is when we apply AI to
science, these limitations also crop up
in our scientific workflows that we're
using AI for.
So this is some this is some more work
that we did where where I show you where
we found one of these limitations.
And
and so what we did here was we trained a
neural network to carry out simulation
and specifically to carry out simulation
of of earthquakes through through the
earth.
So you don't need to know the exact
workflow,
but
at a very high level, we had a neural
network here.
A
neural network here that took in as
input the structure of the earth and in
particular the velocity of the earth,
which varies depending on the the
geology of the earth.
And then it produced an output which is
basically the seismic response
along the surface of the earth. So
basically the the strength of the
earthquake wherever you are on the
surface.
And what we found is
um
well, so we trained this neural network
with lots of velocity models that
were very simple. So they just had
horizontal layering and a single fault.
And what we found is when we tested that
neural network on a velocity model that
was close to its training data, so you
know, a similar horizontally layered
velocity model with a single fault,
it was able to predict the seismic
response very very accurately.
But as soon as I gave it an input that
was outside of its training
distribution, so a velocity model that
had curves in it or extra faults for
example,
then the the prediction of the network
starts to really suffer and and it
performs much worse.
So this is the issue of generalization
showing up in a scientific workflow.
So this kind of makes a lot of
scientists uneasy when we try and say,
"Okay, we're going to use AI to replace
our existing scientific workflows."
Because we know that
deep learning has these flaws. You know,
it has this lack of interpretability. It
sometimes struggles to generalize and we
also need lots of training data to train
these algorithms.
And this doesn't really sit well with
you know, people to scientists that
understand the traditional way of doing
science, which is which heavily revolves
around this interplay between theory and
experiment.
You know, the traditional way of doing
science is to come up with a a very
explainable
theory,
come up with some hypothesis to test
that theory,
do an experiment and either validate or
tell us that we need to improve that
theory. And and it's this iterative
improvement cycle that we typically go.
And a really important point about that
theory is, you know, a good theory
should be explainable and make novel
predictions and and that's exactly what
deep neural networks struggle to do.
So in the last I would say 5 years or
so, there's been a real uh
change in scientific research using AI.
And what what has happened is
we've now started to see this field
called scientific machine learning
emerge. And what is scientific machine
learning? The core the core thesis of
this field is to not just replace our
scientific workflows with machine
learning,
but to actually tightly combine our
existing scientific understanding, which
we have, you know, centuries of
scientific understanding to to build
upon.
And so we're going to tightly combine
that with our machine learning workflows
and and we call those models scientific
machine learning models.
And we hope that they're more powerful,
more robust, and more interpretable than
just replacing our existing workflow
with with with AI.
So there are there are a whole plethora
of scientific machine learning
techniques that have been proposed and
are being currently researched. This is
a very very hot field right now.
And you might have heard of some of
these techniques already. So for
example, things like physics-informed
neural networks,
differentiable physics,
neural operators, neural differential
equations. A lot of these techniques we
will be covering in this course in in a
lot of detail. So you'll see a lot more
of these to come.
And yeah, this is a very rapidly growing
field. So
there have now been scientific machine
learning workshops, you know, workshops
on combining machine learning with
scientific understanding across all of
the major machine learning conferences
over the last two to three years.
Um
I also did
a keyword search just to look at the
number of publications that contain
these these scientific machine learning
keywords.
So for example, things like
physics-informed neural networks, SciML,
operator learning, differentiable
physics, all of these keywords have have
received exponentially growing numbers
of publications over the last year and
now we're we're really starting to see a
really emergence of this field.
Okay, so I just gave you the kind of
very high-level motivation of the course
and I've hopefully tried to convince you
that AI really is having an impact on
science today. And
it is potentially a very transformative
tool that we can use in science.
So what is the overall goal of this
course?
So we have kind of four big learning
objectives for you. So by the end of the
course,
we would hope that you'll be more aware
of the advanced applications of AI in
the sciences and engineering.
Also to be more familiar with the
specific design, implementation, and
theory behind those algorithms.
We also want you to be realistic about
when you can use AI and when when you
perhaps shouldn't use AI to to
enhance your scientific workflow.
And we also want you to not just
understand
AI techniques, but also how to tightly
combine scientific understanding with
scientific understanding standing with
them.
So to appreciate kind of these key
scientific machine learning concepts and
and themes.
Okay, so so this is the course timeline.
So there's a lot going on in this slide
and I'm going to talk you through it. Um
So we have two lectures a week.
We have the one on Wednesday, which is
today's lecture. And we also have a
lecture on Friday and they're both in
the same room. So here in MLH44.
Alongside the lectures, we also have
tutorials. So these are going to be run
by our TAs and and they will contain
practical exercises, usually coding
exercises,
uh that will complement uh all the
content that we cover in in the
lectures.
Um I'm not going to talk through
exactly the details of each lecture
right now. I'm going to tell you about
the the course overview later on in the
lecture.
Uh but, to give you a very high-level
description, um Sid and I are going to
talk you through uh well, we're first
going to first going to do a brief recap
of deep learning. One of the
prerequisites of the course is to
understand the basics of machine
learning. So, things like optimization
and and supervised learning. So, this
will be quite a fast recap, but
hopefully get everyone on the same page.
Um and then we'll talk about uh
different types of
core scientific machine learning
techniques. And so, we'll first talk
about uh physics-informed neural
networks. Then, we'll talk about the
field of operator learning.
Then, we'll go into a couple of specific
architectures uh or state-of-the-art
architectures that have been used in
science. So, things like um large
language models, graph neural networks,
and fusion models.
Then, we'll talk about uh differential
physics. And then and then at the end,
we have uh
two guest lectures where the the
lecturer will be talking about uh
machine learning in in chemistry and in
biology. So, that should be really
exciting.
Um
Okay.
Oh, the other thing I should say is uh
this schedule um can might change
depending on how quickly we go through
material. And we're also actively
material. So, so a lot of the material
in this course um has been researched in
the last year or or or two. So, so we
are actively changing this course as
well.
Um and there's some So, there are some
practical information as well for the
course. So, so all the materials will be
available on our course Moodle page. So,
this includes uh the lecture recordings
and also the tutorial exercises.
Um we're also running uh Zoom meetings
so that you can join online as well as
being in person.
Um and then what you're probably been
mostly interested in is how we're
assessing the course. So, so the big
thing to to note is that we don't have
any exams for the course.
And all of our assessment is done
through three individual homework
assignments.
So, these are these are individual
assignments that you'll be asked to do
uh and then we do every 4 weeks. And so,
we'll release the first assignment on
the 8th of March and then it will be due
to be submitted uh 4 weeks later. So, on
on the 5th of April.
Um so, these assignments will be related
to the content that we cover in the
lectures and in the tutorials.
Um and all the specifics of what we're
going to ask you to do and what you'll
be asked to deliver uh for each of those
assignments will be given when we submit
the when we release the assignment. So,
you'll you'll have a very detailed
description.
And you can also talk to our TAs who
will be helping us uh mark those those
assignments.
So, our teaching assistants uh for this
course are Bogdan and and Victor and
they'll be very happy to to help you.
You can also message us on on Google.
There's there's uh ways that you can
connect with us.
Uh
Okay.
So, uh
yeah, I've been talking for a while. So,
we'll just take a quick break and then
we'll we'll get back to it in 5 minutes
or so. So,
Okay. So, how does the rest of this
lecture look? Um so, what I just gave
you was the course motivation and and
the overview of the course.
So, now what we're going to spend the
rest of the lecture talking about are
some of the key scientific tasks uh
that we want to study in science um in a
very general way.
And then we'll I'm also going to try and
explain to you how AI can help or
machine learning can help solve those
scientific tasks.
So, I'm going to talk at a fairly
abstract level um across many different
disciplines um
but, it turns out there are a lot of
different scientific tasks that are
general or or like this the common
across different disciplines. And so,
these these tasks are uh simulation
problems, uh inverse control, data
assimilation problems, equation
discovery, and anomaly detection. So,
I'm I'm going to talk about those tasks
in in general.
Um and then at the end of the lecture,
I'm going to give more of an overview
into scientific machine learning and and
tell you more about about how to more
tightly integrate scientific
understanding into into machine
learning.
And and try and motivate some of the key
scientific uh kind of tools and
techniques that we'll be studying in in
much more detail in in the upcoming
lectures.
So, what are our learning objectives for
the lecture? So, so we have three of
them. So,
by the end of the lecture, you should
hopefully understand why AI is uh so
useful in sciences and and the impact
that it's having.
You should also understand the typical
types of scientific tasks that we're we
try to solve uh using machine learning.
And uh
you will also understand why it's the
field of scientific machine learning is
this and why it's a good idea to to
combine scientific understanding with
machine learning.
Okay. So, let's let's talk about some
key scientific tasks that are very
common across many different scientific
domains.
And so, before I talk about scientific
tasks, I should really talk about
differential equations or or in fact
partial differential equations.
And these are really the building blocks
behind uh science.
And they really determine or describe
the world around us in a very elegant
way. Um
From from the smallest scales, for
example, you know, describing how atoms
evolve over time
uh using the Schrödinger equation,
to the very large scales, uh thinking
about how uh black holes and their
dynamics. And these are Einstein's field
equations.
They also help us understand the Earth.
So, I showed you an example of climate
simulation in the first slide of the of
the lecture. So, you know, the
fundamental equations behind these
dynamics are the Navier-Stokes
equations.
Um we also know that differential
equations can help us understand biology
and and in particular uh the
reaction-diffusion equation helps us
understand how patterns form when that
when animal skin uh are growing.
So, so PDEs are fundamental and uh we
place quite a large focus on um solving
problems related to PDEs um in this
course uh for this reason.
Um so, we'll be talking a lot more about
uh yeah, how to use AI in the context of
differential equations in this course.
Okay. So, so now let's get on to these
key scientific tasks.
And as I said at the um when I talked
about the the the lecture overview, I'm
going to give you examples of specific
scientific tasks as I'm talking through,
but I really encourage you to think um
at the higher kind of abstract level,
maybe in your field of science, uh
if there are any analogous tasks that
you're interested in or or you think are
hard to solve uh in in your specific
field.
So, so um the first task is simulation.
And and
what I'm going to try and do here is to
describe it at a very high level.
And to do that, I'm going to say we have
some uh physical system
and we have um some input conditions to
that physical system uh which I'm just
going to describe by A.
We also have a physical model of that
system. And this more often than not is
some set of differential equations, for
example.
And then given those input conditions
and that physical model, uh
what the task of simulation is to um
predict the resulting properties given
those input conditions. So, so B in this
equation.
Um
So, this is obviously a very high
high-level uh description of simulation.
And and depending on the actual task,
the underlying physical model can be
much more complicated in terms of the
the maths that we use.
So, here here's an example of
simulation. Um
it's an example of modeling an
earthquake um
through the structure of the Earth.
Uh
and uh
you know, simulation in an in a broad
sense is is is crucial for many
different scientific tasks. And it's
really important for um you know,
understanding understanding different
scientific phenomena and predicting how
they behave.
And it and simulation is usually used as
a starting point for many other
scientific tasks. So, so for example, um
we might want to see how uh
the seismic response here varies at the
surface of the Earth depending on where
the earthquake is. And we might want to
do some kind of uh modeling or hazard
prediction based based on that
simulation.
So, the underlying PDE here that um I'm
running the simulation using is is the
acoustic wave equation. So, this is a
very very well-known uh familiar
equation.
Um so, just to lay out more explicitly
for you using that framework that I just
described. So,
um we're trying to predict B here. And B
in this case of the simulation is the
wave field. Uh so, it's a solution of
that differential equation,
uh which is essentially the pressure of
of the seismic wave
um you
as a function of space and space and
time.
And the the inputs of the simulation uh
is the velocity model. So, this is the
our model of the Earth, the structure of
the Earth.
Uh and also the location of the of the
earthquake. And and given those input
conditions, we want to predict the
predict the seismic wave field.
And then F here is is our differential
equation, our our wave equation. Uh but,
also as as well as knowing the equation,
we also need some method to to solve the
equation. And
for example, a very common method is to
use a finite difference solver when
we're doing the when we're solving the
wave equation.
Okay.
So, yeah, how do how do we solve
simulation problems? Well, traditionally
we use numerical methods.
Most PDEs,
especially with
you know, realistic input conditions are
not analytically solvable and we have to
resort to numerical techniques.
And this is
a massive field by its own right
and has been studied for decades or
more.
So, we have many, many different
approaches for numerically solving
differential equations and you know,
popular methods which I'm sure many have
studied already things like finite
difference solvers, finite element
solvers, spectral methods, the main
decomposition methods, but the list goes
on and there there is a lot of lot of
techniques out there to to choose from.
So, what are the challenges of
simulation that we that we have today?
Um, well, what I already told you at the
start of the lecture that the big
Typically, the big challenge of
simulation is the computational cost
that it takes to to run these numerical
methods, these finite element, solvers.
So, this is a this is a video from from
NASA or it's a simulation from NASA
simulating the exhaust from a from a
rocket.
And this is a super complicated
simulation. It's multi-physics,
multi-phase simulation.
And just to to run, you know, this
couple of seconds of of simulation
took 500 million grid cells in the
simulation and ran for several weeks on
thousands of cores. So,
this cost millions of dollars to run
simulation.
And that's very restrictive. What we
would really love to do is to run this
simulation maybe thousands of times
varying the design of the rocket to help
us optimize that system and produce an
efficient rocket, but it's just not
practically possible. We just limited by
the computer.
So, if we could speed this up with
machine learning, it could be
potentially transformative in the way
that we can, you know, design these
systems.
There are a couple of other big
challenges as well.
Um, methods like finite element methods,
we spend a
a lot of time just designing a
appropriate mesh for that simulation.
That can take a huge amount of human
effort just to do it. Like I'm talking
weeks weeks of design.
On top of that, a lot of our established
simulation codes, so for example,
OpenFOAM is very popular fluid dynamics
code.
This code base takes
has millions of lines of code and and
can be very difficult to build upon or
understand if you're just coming into
the into the field.
Okay, so we're now going to move on to
the the next class of problems and and
this class of problems are inverse
problems.
And so, what is inverse problem at a
very high level?
So, we have the same equation, but now
what we're trying to focus on is instead
of predicting the outputs of the system
is we actually want to want to predict
or infer the input conditions of the
system.
Given given some observations of of the
system. So, given some observations B
and an understanding of the physical
model, what were the input conditions
that produced those observations?
Okay, so let's think about framing that
seismic simulation task as an inverse
problem. So, so the the
the inverse problem would be given, you
know, observations of the of the wave
field. So, suppose we have geophones
that measure measure the pressure
pressure response
on these surfaces of the earth, for
example.
Can we figure out where the earthquake
was and maybe even what the structure of
the earth was as well, the underlying
velocity model?
And yeah, these these are basic these
are off across many different fields of
science. So, these are a couple of
example inverse problems. So, this is
this is seismic imaging. We also have
MRI imaging
is another example of an inverse
problem.
Also, image denoising, removing noise
from images can be thought of as an
inverse problem.
Or estimate infection rates, design
problems, the the list goes on.
So, so how do we solve inverse problems?
Um,
so fundamentally, we we can frame an
inverse problem as a search problem.
It's, you know, given given a value of
B, let's try and find or search for the
value of A that gives that that value of
B.
And it's often very useful to frame this
as an optimization problem specifically.
And in an optimization problem, what we
do is we define some objective function
or or loss function
that we want to try and minimize.
So, you know, a common one might just be
the the L2 norm between the prediction
given some
guess value of what the input conditions
A are
and and the true observed values B.
So, then if if this loss function and is
differentiable, for example, then we can
evaluate the gradient of this this loss
with respect to A.
Which also, by the way, requires that
your your solver F is also
differentiable. So, your finite
difference, finite element solver is
differentiable.
Then we can use methods gradient descent
methods to to to optimize and solve for
for A.
If we don't have access to the
gradients, there there are also many
other gradient free methods we could
use. So,
things like evolutionary algorithms,
Bayesian optimization
brute force search in some cases
can can work.
So, let me just lay out using gradient
descent to solve inverse problems
explicitly for you.
So, as I said before, we we have this
we have this
objective function on the top here.
Um, or loss function. And
what we do is we start with a model on
the top left here.
We do forward modeling to predict what
the values of B are to get some
synthetic data.
We evaluate that loss function
and that that decides how good that
model is.
And then we update update the model
using gradient descent and then
using this iterative for loop
or or yeah, iterative loop
we end up with a final guess of what the
model model is.
So, um,
just for later, this is really exactly
the same algorithm that we use to train
deep deep neural networks and this is
actually kind of interesting and we'll
go into the links of inverse problems
and deep neural training deep neural
networks in more detail in the course
later. So,
a lot of the tricks that we use to train
deep neural networks can be used to help
us solve inverse problems as well.
And vice versa.
Uh, so yeah, specifically for that
seismic inverse problem
that I described
here our observational data would be the
wave field that I showed you before and
we would start with some guess of what
the velocity model would be and
usually we're just start with a very
smooth approximation of the average
velocity. So,
we run this cycle of of training and we
end up hopefully with with a model
that's close to the true the true earth.
So, this is actually a real
gradient descent algorithm running on on
on this this wave field data.
Um, we're doing this for loop. We're
updating the gradients and and this is
the this is how that guess of the
velocity model changes as we update the
gradient.
Um, so in geophysics, this is actually
known as full waveform inversion. This
is this is the
inverse problem problem's name.
And what you can see, there's quite a
few interesting things that are going on
here. Um,
first of all, it does actually get quite
a good guess of of the
true velocity model and also of the
estimated wave field based on that true
on that guess velocity model.
But what's interesting is that it
doesn't uh
uh update the model outside of where the
wave field has traveled.
And so, this makes sense. Like there's
no information outside of where the wave
field hasn't traveled yet and so you
can't understand what the velocity is
before it's traveled there.
Another interesting thing is it it gets
most of the velocity model right, but
really starts to map up in the in the
left-hand side there and gets some
really weird anomalies in in the in the
estimated velocity.
And so, this is a challenge of inverse
problems is that
in many cases, in many real world cases
the observational data that we have
doesn't uniquely allow us to uniquely
determine what the the solution of the
inverse problem is.
Um,
and also, even if you have enough
information
the loss function still might be very
complicated and have lots of local
minima in it in it that you might still
not converge even if you have enough
information.
Which is probably what is happening
here. We have a lot of information, but
the loss function is probably very
complex.
So, so there are there actually a lot of
challenges with inverse problems and in
practice, they are extremely difficult
to solve.
Um,
and yeah, the biggest reason is this
ill-posedness is what I mentioned. So,
there's often not enough information in
the observational data to uniquely
determine what that that solution is.
Um,
another issue which contributes to the
ill-posedness
is observations can be sparse.
They can also be very noisy and again,
that that makes them harder to solve.
The final thing is um,
when we're running, for example, that
gradient descent loop
doing optimization
we have to evaluate that forward solver
often thousands of times to to carry out
gradient descent. So, I already told you
that simulation, you know, evaluate
doing numerical simulation can be very
expensive. So, if we have to run that
thousands of times, inverse problems are
even more expensive than than simulation
in many cases.
So, so yeah, this is definitely a very
difficult difficult thing to solve. So,
this is another example of an inverse
problem on the left here
is doing computer tomography. So,
basically doing x-rays.
Uh, and so, what is the inverse problem
in in this in this situation?
So, we what we have is an an x-ray
source where the solid is there. We have
some media that that source is going
through.
And that media has some absorption of of
the x-rays. And that absorption depends
as a function of space. So, you know,
different parts of your body absorb
x-rays in different different amounts.
And you can interpret that as an image
that allows you to see into the body.
And then we just record those x-rays
along with the detector at many
locations.
And you can see that um
if we just have a single single uh
depending on the number of lines that we
record, the number of x-rays we receive.
That really determines the the
ill-posedness of the of the of the
inverse problem. If we have lots of
lines, then we could get a really good
image.
But if we have very few detectors, then
then it becomes very difficult to
reconstruct that image. And And you can
see
the actual data that we receive is the
intensity of the x-rays that the
detector doesn't look anything like you
know, but that can be pulled from the
time domain.
And we have to reconstruct from that
time domain the the original image. And
this is an example of
one particular inverse algorithm called
a filtered back projection algorithm
that that is doing that. And it's
clearly not getting the exact answer.
But that is a very noisy estimate of the
of the true solution.
Okay.
So, related to inverse problems um
are control and data assimilation
problems. And and it can help to think
of these as different classes of inverse
problems.
So, so what is a control problem? Well,
a control a control problem is, you
know, given a system of differential
equations,
can we add some
action or force into those differential
equations that controls the system or
the the state of the system?
So, a classic example of control
classic a classic control problem is is
the inverted pendulum. Trying to
You can imagine a pendulum on a cart.
And the task is to move the cart such
that the pendulum ends up inverted like
this. And this is a very unstable
equilibrium.
Uh the underlying equations of motions
are here. I'm not going to describe them
in detail. But what we're trying to do
is
vary the force here so that so that the
final state dependent ends up there
you know, the angle is tends towards
zero.
So, we can frame this as an inverse
problem where
A here is the force that we're applying
to the cart.
F is the differential equations and the
way that we solve them. And then B is
the condition that theta as a function
of time tends to zero.
Another
type of problem is a data assimilation
problem. This is a task, for example,
where we have noisy measurements of the
the pendulum itself. And we want to
perhaps infer the starting position of
the pendulum or maybe the path of the
position through time.
So again, we could then say A here is
the thing that we want to understand,
which is the final position
of the pendulum.
B are perhaps noisy measurements of X
and theta.
And then F is
again the model that we have. And
perhaps a noise model added on top of
the if the noisy noisy measurements.
And the the final kind of type of
inverse problem is a design problems.
And so, this is the problem that I'm
talking about when we were designing
space space rockets, for example.
What we want to do is we have some
physical system. And then we want to
optimize the design of that system to
you know, to maximize certain metrics of
that of that system.
So, another example would be designing
the shape of an airfoil so that we
maximize the lift of the airfoil. And
the parameters that we have to play with
are maybe the shape of the airfoil and
the angle of attack of of the of the
wing.
So, so this is again can be thought of
as a as an inverse type problem.
Okay. So, we're just going to move on to
the the last class of scientific tasks.
And this is actually understanding F
itself.
So, this is what I would describe as
equation discovery or model discovery.
You know, we might have some
observations of the initial conditions
of the system and maybe some
observations of its output, like how it
behaves. We we might not fully
understand what the underlying
differential equation is or or whatever
the model is.
And this is actually the case for many
different domains of of science. So, for
example, experimental fluid dynamics is
trying to understand
the kind of underlying equations of of
fluids.
Um
So, yeah, how how do we do it? Well,
traditionally this relied upon, you
know, remarkable human intuition. I I
had to put a picture of Einstein here
because we're ETH.
Um
But
uh
Yeah, and and and to be able to come up
with a good theory is what I was
describing before, having this interplay
between designing a theory, carrying out
experiments, validating that theory. And
it's this iterative cycle done done by
humans mostly.
So, from from a from a computational
standpoint, um it's
or in the context of this kind of um
uh framework that I've been describing,
you can kind of think of it as some sort
of inverse problem where we're given
again some observation data. We want to
understand some underlying
uh description of the system.
But here we're actually trying to
predict the model. And this And the
hallmarks of a good model is that yeah,
it should be explainable, it should be
generalizable, and it should make novel
predictions that we can validate using
using experiment.
So, maybe a more specific
or or
yeah, a specific example of of model
discovery
would be anomaly detection.
And so, this isn't discovering the
entire model, but it's doing one small
part of that discovery process, which is
detecting anomalies anomalies in your
data, which can lead to you updating
your model or or discovering a new type
of
physics, for example.
So, yeah, an example of anomaly
detection would be
the detecting exoplanets as I was
discussing. So, this is the transit
method, which I already explained.
But this is challenging for a number of
reasons.
I already explained that the noise in
this data makes it very hard for humans
to detect patterns and anomalies in the
data.
It can also be really hard to detect
anomalies, particularly if they come
from physics that we don't currently
understand. So, they're out of
distribution or from unexplained
physics.
And very often anomalies are kind of
like looking for a needle in a haystack.
They're very infrequent. So, so if you
think of for example, particle
collisions and like specific particles
that we're looking for in particle
colliders.
Okay.
So, what I've got in the next like
section is just a couple of examples of
how deep learning can help each of these
tasks.
So, I've got an example of deep learning
improving simulation. I've got an
example of deep learning improving
inverse problems. And then an example of
deep learning helping us to discover
underlying equations of a of a system.
So, at a high level, how can deep
learning help? So, as we saw before,
ChatGPT summarizes very nicely for us.
It can help us improve the accuracy of
these of these
techniques. It can improve the
efficiency, the automation, and
discovery of um
uh
of our scientific workflows.
Okay. So, so here's an example using
machine learning for science. And it's
the example that I already showed you
using
deep neural networks to carry out
climate simulations or weather
simulations.
And so, this is FourCastNet, which I
showed you this animation on the on the
right here.
So, how what is what exactly is
FourCastNet? Well,
FourCastNet is this deep neural network
called a a Fourier neural operator.
So, it is a it is just a neural network
architecture. It's based on convolutions
convolutional networks.
Um but what's interesting is it does uh
it does the convolution in the in the
Fourier domain. So, you know, we know
that a convolution
in the frequency domain is just a
multiplication essentially.
And what's what's unique about the
Fourier neural operator, rather than
just a standard convolutional network,
is that it when it does that Fourier
transform, it actually clips some of the
frequencies. So, it throws away some of
the high frequencies
in in the input data essentially.
And then it times it by the weight
matrix, which is doing the convolution,
and then and then does the inverse
Fourier transform back.
So, this is interesting. There's a lot
of There's a lot to be said about
uh the motivation behind Fourier neural
operators and operator learning in
general, which we are going to talk
about a lot more in the course.
But for now, you can just think of this
as a kind of a an intelligent neural
network architecture, which is just
preferring low frequencies in in the in
the inputs.
So, it has like some prior saying
we should model like low frequency
trends better.
Um And it turns out that this model is
just really good at carrying out weather
weather weather simulation. And the most
important thing is that it is four to
five orders of magnitude faster than
solving Navier-Stokes equations or or
like a full-blown climate model using
using traditional numerical techniques.
Okay. So, now let's talk about how can
we use deep learning to solve inverse
problems?
So, I showed you this
you know, classical gradient descent
algorithm for solving inverse problems
that is often used.
So, how can we put machine learning into
this algorithm to try and improve the
performance of it?
So, there there are many different ways
to to use machine learning to solve
inverse problems. And this is just one
particular way. Again, we in the course,
we're going to cover many different ways
to do this.
Um but one particular way is to use a
neural network to actually
improve the estimates of the gradient or
the step that that you want to take
each iteration of the of the gradient
descent
movement.
So we know that when we estimate the
gradient here in the loss function, that
gradient, especially if the inverse
problem is ill-posed, will be very noisy
and it won't take us in a step that is
exactly the right direction to solve the
inverse problem.
You know, the loss loss landscape is
going to be very complex and and the
gradient direction is maybe not the best
step
to take.
So the idea is to train a neural
network, take that gradient and update
it so that it takes a better step. Um
and how do we learn that neural network?
How do we learn to take a better step?
Well, we write this algorithm down and
we actually differentiate through the
entire algorithm uh using auto
differentiation um
to train the weights of the network and
the and and the loss function that we
use to train the network is to match
the output final algorithm final model
here to the many example inverse
problems.
Um I'll be talking a lot more about this
when we talk about differential physics
in in the kind of second half of the of
the course.
But it turns out if you if you do this,
if you if you train a neural network to
improve the gradient steps, um we can
start getting a much better
performance of the of the inverse
algorithm and
um it starts to remove some of the noise
the noise present from the ill-posedness
of the of the problem.
Okay.
So the final thing to
task to talk about is equation
discovery. So how how is machine
learning help us discover the underlying
equations of of of the system?
So again, this is now becoming its own a
whole field and this is just one example
of the many different techniques to to
to do this.
Um and
what this method is doing is very
simple. So so you can imagine
we have some observations here of some
physical system.
Um we don't understand what the
underlying differential equation is yet.
We just know that uh we have the
observations of some variable U, the
solution of the of the equations and and
how it evolves with time. So these are
our noisy noisy measurements.
So how do we discover the underlying
differential equation that this U of T
obeys?
So it's very simple. We just first we
fit a neural network
uh
uh to this data. So we have a neural
network function here, a neural network
of X and T that directly tries to fit
this data. So it's just a a curve fit to
that data.
The next step is to compute various
gradients um of of that neural network,
that trained neural network. So you
know, that neural network function is
just a mathematical function and we have
analytical gradients that we can we can
get from from that function. So you
know, the the derivative of the output
of the network with respect to its
inputs, so dU by dT and dU by dX.
So what we do is we just compute a whole
library of these of these gradients
at many different random X X and T
locations and querying the whole
function.
And then to discover the underlying
equation given those gradients, we just
carry out sparse linear regression over
over those gradients. So we So we make
the assumption that for example, the the
time derivative dU dT here
is a linear combination of all these
different gradients.
And that's that's
typically how we could frame a
differential equation. You If you think
about writing a differential equation
out, it's just a linear combination of
these gradients.
So that's the assumption that we make
about the system and then we're going to
try and learn each of the coefficients
of those
different gradients to actually kind of
discover the underlying equation.
Now I wouldn't say that this is
uh full-blown discovery of a of a
physical model. It's just linear
regression essentially.
But it is a starting way to kind of
understand or to start discovering
discovering the equations.
Um
So yeah, this is a paper that came out
in Nature Communications a couple of
years ago
and it does it very well. So it they
could discover this underlying equation
here. So this is the the Burgers'
equation for this fluid problem.
Okay. So what I just did was I told you
told you at a high level the kind of
general scientific tasks that we're
interested in solving in science and I
gave you a very small flavor of how
machine learning can help us solve those
those tasks.
So now I'm going to spend the final part
of the lecture just talking about this
field of scientific machine learning,
which I already said was a way to
combine our existing scientific
understanding with machine learning in a
much in a very tight way to produce more
powerful and more robust and more
interpretable models.
So I'm going to give you a
more of an overview of this field.
So yeah, I I described this already. So
we know that
deep learning when it's just naively
applied to a scientific workflows has
all these issues. So it has the lack of
interpretability, poor generalization,
needs a lot of training data. And so
this is what SciML is doing is we're
trying to combine our scientific
understanding into these algorithms.
So how do we actually do that? Like what
are the different ways that people have
researched and proposed to actually
blend understanding with with neural
networks in particular?
So I like to class them into kind of
three broad categories.
And we'll be explaining these different
categories throughout the course and and
examples of different techniques within
these categories.
But at a very high level, there are kind
of yeah, three ways that you can you can
blend scientific understanding into a
into a neural network.
The first way is
through the loss function. So this is
the the loss function that you use to
train a neural network.
Um rather than just training the network
to reproduce lots and lots of scientific
data, you can actually put physical
constraints into that loss function. So
for example, you can tell the neural
network that you must conserve mass or
you must conserve energy or or you must
obey for example, the underlying
differential equations.
And this is a really powerful way of
improving the performance of these
models and also allowing them to rely on
less data.
Uh
and so there's a lot to be said about
this and and a specific example of
physics-informed neural networks and and
these have become very popular in in the
last five years or so.
So we have
three three or four lectures just on
physics-informed neural networks.
The next kind of broad category of doing
SciML um is to change the architecture
of the neural network itself so that it
encodes kind of scientific constraints
inside the architecture.
Um this is kind of a hard constraint,
whereas training the changing the loss
function is more of a soft constraint.
So for example, we could have specific
layers in the neural network which
encode symmetries that we know about at
a very deep level.
Uh they could also encode, you know,
energy conservation, rotational
invariance. There's a lot of really
interesting tricks to improve the
performance of of scientific models that
we that we that we train.
And the final kind of uh
approach, which is probably the broadest
approach,
is what I call hybrid methods.
And so rather than replacing our
traditional scientific algorithm or
workflow with a neural network, even if
it's got some kind of kind of
constraints in it,
in this hybrid method, we actually try
to tightly combine a neural network
inside of a traditional algorithm.
So for example, that inverse problem
that I was describing where we had a
gradient descent even we put a neural
network into the into a small part of
that algorithm.
So So these can be very powerful and and
also very interpretable methods and and
again, we have uh two or three lectures
describing techniques in this area. So
So for example, things like neural
differential equations, differential
physics, uh things like this can be
classed as hybrid methods.
Okay.
So actually um I I said SciML is this
rapidly growing field and there are a
whole plethora of techniques
out there uh
of which some of them we're going to
cover in detail.
And this is actually a a plot that I
made in my thesis. This is already out
of date. So this I did this in 2022. Uh
but I I think it's I think it's still
useful to to see this plot and think of
it in this way.
And so what I did is I just broke down
in a table
along along the top here are these three
different scientific tasks that we're
trying to carry out, these general
tasks. So So simulation, inversion, and
equation discovery.
And what I did on the on the rows here
is I I
defined which SciML technique that
research paper was was using to solve
that task. So you have the categories
here, the the architectural techniques,
the loss function techniques, and hybrid
approaches as I was just describing.
Um
and what you can see is that there is
research that covers that entire plane
plane of possibility.
So you know, you can use architectural
approaches to carry out equation
discovery. You can use hybrid approaches
to carry out simulation. There's a lot
of really interesting
areas and subareas of in this field of
SciML that are focusing in these
different parts of this table.
There are also some gaps over there.
Like I said, I I caveat this that this
is already out of date and so there's a
lot of research that I am not putting up
on this.
Okay.
Another way to think about SciML
techniques, which is often very useful,
is to think of the spectrum.
So
what is this spectrum? So on on the left
of this spectrum, we have what I would
describe as naive methods for carrying
out scientific workflows. This is
essentially just taking our scientific
data and training a black box neural
network to to reproduce that data.
And then on the right we would just have
traditional our traditional scientific
workflow. So these don't use any machine
learning, no deep no deep networks at
all. It's just our you know, things like
finite difference modeling,
traditional inverse algorithms, etc.
And so what you can do is you can place
these sign out techniques inside along
the spectrum somewhere.
And their position on the spectrum just
depends on for example, how much
scientific understanding they blend into
the model and
uh different amounts in a very
wishy-washy way. It's not I'm not
describing this in the precise way.
Uh different amounts that you can put
scientific understanding into the model.
So you might think towards the left here
you would have models like where we just
change the loss function. We're not
really changing the architecture.
That's kind of a soft constraint. It
might be more towards the left.
But then these hybrid approaches where
we're where we're building on top of an
existing traditional numerical model
might have a lot of hard constraints in
the physics of the model and so it might
be more towards the right hand side.
So this is just a very useful way of of
thinking about sign out techniques.
There are other kind of world properties
that emerge from the left hand side and
the right hand side. So so on the left
hand side these models you could think
of them as being fully learned,
uh fully driven by that data and not
having any kind of physical constraints
in the in the model.
And on the right
uh you wouldn't need any learning at
all. You don't need any data and and the
physics is just hard hard coded into the
into the into the model.
So yeah, there are subcategories within
each of these
uh each of these three different sign
out approaches.
Uh and we'll be covering all the all of
these circled areas throughout
throughout the course. So I'm not going
to talk about them now.
Okay, so
let's just go back to the course
overview. We're we're nearly done.
Um and now that I've told you about sign
out in a bit more detail, uh we'll just
talk about the overview of the course in
a in a little bit more detail. So I've
already done the course introduction and
like I said we're going to recap very
quickly the an introduction to deep
learning to make sure we're all on the
same page.
Then we'll talk about physics and formal
networks for a couple of lectures and
and these like I said are methods that
change the loss function of the network
to incorporate physics constraints.
Then we'll talk about operator learning
and this is
typically to to learn solutions to
differential equations or to solve
problems related to differential
equations and to learn operators rather
than functions.
Uh and you could think of these for
example, that Fourier neural operator
that I talked about, you could think of
these as as clever architectures for
defining neural networks that contain
some kind of kind of constraints of our
system.
Then we're then we'll move on to a block
of lectures where we'll be talking about
some state of the art models. So things
like transformers, graph networks,
diffusion models and how they're having
a big impact in science. And and again,
these are very cleverly designed
architectures that incorporate
things like rotational invariance for
example,
um if you're modeling like molecules.
Um
Uh so you can think of maybe these are
sophisticated architectures
specific for science.
Um and then we'll have the final set of
lectures which we'll be talking about
these hybrid workflows and we'll be
talking about a very important concept
in sign out called you know, just the
idea of differentiability and and
differentiable physics.
And we'll talk about neural differential
equations and some some some
uh a lecture on symbolic regression and
equation discovery as well.
And then we have the guest lecture at
the end talking about applications in
chemistry and biology.
Okay, so I covered a lot um
but if I was to summarize and what I
want you to take away from the lecture
is
AI really is driving big breakthroughs
in science today and it's really become
uh
really received a lot of attention in in
the public over the last year
especially.
Um and it's been driven by these big
changes and fundamental breakthroughs in
in AI over the last decade.
And I would say I would go so far as to
say AI is actually fundamentally
changing the way that we carry out
science. It's it's really changing us
changing our mindset and how we do
scientific discovery.
And the the latest and and state of the
art in this area is scientific machine
learning. It's not only using the
machine learning model but also
incorporating scientific constraints to
improve the performance of that model.
So yeah, thanks a lot for coming. I'll
see you on Friday for the for the next
lecture. Um yeah, see you then. Thank
you.